[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what you're listening to
is the who in hymn number six the oldest
piece of music that actually could be
reconstructed
it was discovered in the royal palace of
ugarit northern canaan
now modern day syria and is believed to
say back to 1600
bce some 3 400 years ago
the song itself was inscribed on a small
clay tablet
and was discovered in the early 1950s
along with 36 other tablets
but the who in him number six is the
only tablet that was preserved well
enough
to be read and eventually performed
the tablet itself contains instructions
for a song on a liar
an instrument that looks like a small
harp and is written in a dialect of the
ancient hurian language
it also includes partially obscured
lyrics that appear to be a prayer to
nikal
the goddess of orchards the version you
see on screen is translation by hans
johan thiel
and is considered to be the closest to
the original spirit of the song
while the hearing hymn is the oldest
piece of music that can be reconstructed
it is not till a song that exists that
title goes to the lipit ishtar
which is another tablet discovered in
sumer monday iraq
but this time from 1950 bce
roughly 4 000 years ago
it's made up of instructions on house
player him but the trouble is
it's only a small fragment of a large
piece of work and so its instructions do
not give us enough information to
reconstruct the actual song
the oldest film music in its broader
sense is the many musical instruments
mostly bone flutes that have been
unearthed in prehistoric excavation
sites
the oldest musical instrument ever
discovered is the hoefl's flute
dated to around 35 000 to 40 000 years
ago
making it the earliest evidence of music
ever been performed by humans
and whilst we're still able to produce a
sound on these instruments we don't know
what kind of songs were performed on
them
so back to the hearing hymn decode the
song itself proved to be a challenge
unlike our standard sheet music which
notates pitch and duration
the hue in hymn gives instructions on
where a musician needs to position their
fingers on the instrument
it doesn't give any information on how
the lie was tuned
nor does it give lengths and durations
of the notes then finally
to make it more confusing the interval
system on the tablet was unclear
and required some creative thinking to
figure out the first attempt to decode
it was in 1974 by dr ann kilmer
there are no performances of a version
online so here's the digitized edition
of our song
but by far the most popular attempt was
dr richard dunbrill in 1998.
his version sounds as follows
[Music]
[Music]
today there are many other
interpretations of the song done by
artists all across the world
so i've linked them in the description
below as well as academic papers and
links for any further reading
and whilst the real melody of the human
hymn will be likely lost in history
these reconstructions act as a bridge to
the music of ancient and forgotten
peoples
many thousands of years ago
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed the video let me know if
there's any topics you'd like me to
cover
if you'd like to see more like comment
but most will subscribe to the channel
until next time goodbye